let's talk about what's going on with
gretchen carlson the former Fox News
anchor and her lawsuit against News
Corporation the parent company of Fox
News i'll give you the headline first up
News Corporation the parent company of
Fox News has settled gretchen carlson
sexual harassment lawsuit for 20 million
dollars the allegations of sexual
harassment took out the chairman of Fox
News Roger Ailes of course he escaped it
with a paltry 40 million dollar golden
parachute and then uh a settlement that
we now have learned is in the 20 million
dollar range for gretchen carlson not a
good day at fox news yesterday 20
million dollar settlement for gretchen
carlson uh greta van susteren and we'll
talk about this later also quit but
we'll we'll get to that a little bit
later in the show and specialists who
work in employment law say that the
twenty million-dollar payout to gretchen
carlson is the largest known settlement
for a single plaintiff sexual harassment
suit there have been 20 million dollar
settlements when you have a group of
plaintiffs saying we've we've all been
sexually harassed but this is a 20
million dollar settlement just for
gretchen carlson and fascinatingly this
tells us a lot about how these incidents
often work rachel roger ailes the guy
accused by twenty women of sexual
harassment gets 40 million dollars when
he resigns gretchen carlson one of the
victims of sexual harassment gets 20
million dollars the guy who did the
harassing came way a came out way ahead
in terms of the money and i'm sure it's
no shock to you that this is the way it
worked out there's no shock at all but
it's also kind of a deceptive culture in
general because i feel like she kind of
painted herself as this
anti-intellectual and right and and was
saying okay i need to google certain
words because i don't know their meaning
and and then she's also educated by
Stanford and Oxford so I don't really
understand if this is just a product of
the culture there or if maybe this is
someone saying okay he was he was still
in power so he's going to come off in a
better place than she is later we're
going to talk about phyllis schlafly who
passed away and
implicit contrast between what she stood
for deliberately and what she actually
represents gretchen carlson in her
character that she played on fox news as
rachel is pointing out stood for the one
who was not concerned about proactively
advocating for women's rights in her I'm
the Fox News of blonde talking head
personality she stood for the idea that
the free market should decide and that
everything is just fine and women are
making just as much money as men in the
gender pay gap is not something we
should worry about etcetera and she
ended up being a victim of the system
that she pretended didn't exist and some
people still believe Roger Ailes did
absolutely nothing wrong that News
Corporation settled this because they
just wanted to go away if you have 20
allegations of sexual harassment against
the guy you forced to resign and people
know that he resigned with a 40 million
dollar golden parachute if you thought
you could clean this up PR wise by not
settling the lawsuit my guess is you
would try to do that because paying some
120 million dollars is something you're
only going to do if it's better optics
than actually seeing this continue and
there's no doubt in my mind whatsoever
that uh that the fact that Fox News
settled the gretchen carlson case and
two other cases by the way of those
roughly 20 women so far is because it
would have been even worse for them if
these things actually went into trial or
arbitration I've talked about how people
of all ages but particularly Millennials
are owning cars less and participating
more in the sharing economy and one of
the more popular options is zip car
which gets you a car when you want it
when you need it they offer all sorts of
cars SUVs hybrids whatever you need it
includes insurance and it includes gas
you just pay for the time that you
actually use the car and you can reserve
the car online from your smartphone over
the phone then you unlock it with your
zipcard each car share member reduces
their personal co2 emissions by between
1100 and 1,600 pounds per year for our
audience zipcar is offering $25
driving credit if you sign up at joined
zipcar dot-com / David support our show
reduce your carbon emissions and you're
spending on cars sign up at join zipcar
dot-com / David